en la incertidumbre marcan el día
después de una histórica huelga y
masivas protestas que junto al cese del
ministro de defensa y la división del
ejército han forzado netaniagua a
congelar un mes su drástica reforma
judicial apuntando ya a ese diálogo
prometido por netanyahu para lograr una
reforma consensuada el presidente Isaac
gerson que llamó al Primer Ministro y a
los líderes opositores el Jair y Benny
gants para mediar e iniciar esas
conversaciones sin embargo Esa mesa de
diálogo ya ha recibido un primer revés
al conocerse que la coalición gobernante
dejó listo para sus últimas dos lecturas
el proyecto de ley que modifica el
comité de selección de jueces desde el
oficialismo han justificado que es solo
un movimiento técnico y que no pretenden
aún votarlo en el parlamento pero
legisladores opositores cuestionaron que
ese borrador ya no puede ser modificado
y lo lleva a negociar en sus palabras
con un arma en su cabeza otra incógnita
rodea al futuro del ministro de defensa
John galán que aún no ha recibido la
notificación oficial de su despido desde
el oficialismo la oposición y hasta
Estados Unidos reclama la neta Yahoo que
su decisión y lo mantenga en el cargo
por otro lado la calma en las calles se
contrasta con una noche de incidentes en
más de 50 manifestantes anti reforma
fueron detenidos sobre todo ante la por
bloquear carreteras mientras que aquí en
Jerusalén facciones de extrema derecha
lideradas por un grupo Ultra
nacionalista simpatizante del club vetar
Jerusalén agredieron a detractores de la
reforma y atacaron a palestinos en la
ciudad vieja para algunos una muestra de
lo que podría pasar si se crea la
guardia nacional que netanyahu ha
prometido a su ministro de seguridad A
cambio de que aceptase aplazar la
reforma